so Greg and I have been in a
relationship for over 10 years now and
we've always wondered whether or not you
could scientifically evaluate how
compatible we or others actually are and
it turns out that researchers are doing
just that they are looking at couples
biology neurology and genetics to figure
out how compatible they actually are so
we decided to take this test and find
out if we're actually meant to be
together
the company that does this is called
instinct chemistry which starts by
taking a swab of DNA we're gonna analyze
our oxytocin levels serotonin receptors
HLA genes and dr4 genes
oxytocin is often called the love
hormone and is related to bonding
affection and empathy there are actually
two versions of the oxytocin receptors
gene the a and the G variant if you have
the G variant it means that the oxytocin
fits in perfectly to the receptor so
when you're stimulated by it you have a
big response but if you have the a
variant it's kind of like a lock-and-key
that doesn't quite fit perfectly and so
the response is actually a lower
stimulation from oxytocin the oxytocin
receptors related a lot to empathy
there's affection but it's also how well
you are able to interpret how the other
person's amazed you are actually G okay
and you are actually you don't get the
same kick out of those if you are a
thinker it's good to sort of communicate
verbally a lot about what you're
thinking because it may not is that I
always like I want to talk about this
here like you always want to talk about
exactly Gracie would be more reading the
emotion reading this is yeah I don't
need the language I need only yeah
exactly so we give this combination the
thinker in the listener at 75 years
and that's because I mean you were
saying that you're very good at talking
and expressing your emotions but in some
cases the thinker is not I think there
is a party that many of you are probably
wondering if the fact that Mitch and I
are gay is going to affect our results
so we actually asked dr. Seabrook what
she thought a lot of the research that
has been done has been on heterosexual
couples what we find is that there is a
similar trend so I wouldn't take your
results and throw them out the window
they are people with a gay couple
contacts us and says they want to take
the test we subsidize the edge late
because there isn't a lot of that
research out there it's true like this
is something that could be so
heteronormative and it's just nice to
know that brilliant scientists are not
making it fully networked serotonin is a
neurotransmitter that contributes to
feelings of happiness and well-being and
we each have two alleles for the
serotonin transporter gene if you end up
having both short alleles you're
actually worse at having your cells
reuptake serotonin which ultimately
characterizes you as more emotional
which means you feel things way more
strongly whether or not they're good or
bad in both directions if you have long
long or long short allele combination
you're actually much more even-tempered
and practical okay so what do you think
you think you're lying I'm lying because
I feel like a lot of times I
relationship I'm like okay let's look at
the bigger picture and let's chill out
and I think that you're short cuz
they're like yeah and you would feel
really good too yeah I feel like if you
had to be one or the other like I I
definitely like identifying more as a
short and I feel like you are okay okay
so you are actually both practical okay
so we're hetero in this case the only
time someone ever told me that everyone
has HLA genes and they control the
makeup of the bacteria on your skin HLA
fragments are also involved with the
formation of your odor because they are
in your sweat and your saliva as well so
we actually sniff out diverse bacteria
and diverse genes in our lovers so that
the offspring that we create will have a
more diverse immune system so as a side
note obviously Greg and I are gonna
our own biological offspring together
but scientists are actually finding that
the same mechanisms that affect
attraction in straight couples are
actually applicable to gay couples as
well so the better somebody smells to
you the more likely they are to have
different genes and the more likely you
are to have that physical attraction
with the person the average couple when
they take this test scores between about
seventy-five and eighty four percent on
compatibility okay so you guys actually
scored seventy-six next up was our
dopamine receptor for gene there are two
common variants in this gene either
seven are or four are if your seven are
it means that you are more risky you're
more likely to jump out of a plane and
go skydiving or gamble or have an affair
it's actually known as the promiscuity
gene but if you are a four are you are
gonna think before you act
you are way less risky okay so neither
of you are seven are plus okay
that's kind of what I thought yeah we're
not as I was like impulsive yeah I'm not
that promiscuous and we're just like you
know we sit at home and like we want a
golden retriever for a compatibility
score we actually give that a 75% a
seven are pluses brings the excitement
in there that is nice actually that's
why we never leave the house I feel like
the risky behavior was probably just cuz
we were young so we should drink more I
don't feel like we're breaking up today
no no Brendon better it's great to find
out that we are averagely compatible but
I think the most important thing that we
took away from this is it felt a lot
like therapy we were able to learn about
ourselves from a physiological and
mental level and we're able to relate in
a different way as to why maybe we argue
or as to why maybe some parts of our
relationship are harder at certain times
it was really nice to be in an
environment where they were looking for
queer people and they really want us to
be a part of it and we did feel like it
definitely made a lot of sense to us and
that is important we really want to
thank the instant chemistry kit team it
was such a cool experience for us so
definitely check it out we'll put links
in the description for you go do it
make sure
subscribe for more videos and we'll see
you next Thursday for a new animated
video